salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien cette vidéo c'est l'épisode 3
de ma série documentaire sur Morgan
Charrière comme hier je vous recommande
fortement d’aller voir les deux premiers
épisodes sinon vraiment vous risquez
d'être largué donc voilà foncez voir ça
avant de regarder cette vidéo et pour
ceux qui ont déjà pu le début de la
série installez-vous confortablement
parce que c'est mon épisode préféré
j'espère qu'il va vous plaire bon
visionnage ah [__]
ah c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai là
une bonne journée
très énervé d'avoir perdu ma ceinture
comme ça
est-ce que le chemin pour l'UFC est fini
tôt je pense pas
mais j'ai plus le droit de perdre
donc moi je prends pas à l'entraînement
direct
et je pense qu'à une chose c'est
vraiment le prochain combat
je vais la récupérer la ceinture il y
aura pas de question
[Musique]
on a un moment qui est très très
agressif j'ai jamais vu comme ça j'ai la
pilule elle est pas passée au dernier
combat du Scénic il n'est pas passé il
est très très agressif
[Musique]
de 2019 à 2021 j'ai été le combattant en
français le plus suivi sur les réseaux
en France et même en Europe avant même
que l'UFC Vienne en France avant que le
MMA soit légal ok on est de retour donc
là il y a des belles surprises qui
arrivent je peux pas
[Musique]
après le combat c'était la merde et
alors j'ai vu sur les réseaux sociaux
oui si ça ça mais lui il a pas le temps
et il est revenue à l'entraînement et
vas-y on va se tape tu vois ce que je
veux dire excuse-moi de parler comme ça
mais c'est ça c'est on arrive et on va
se battre
c'est un état d'esprit où on n'a pas le
temps de se lamenter on n'a pas le temps
voilà c'est le message de Morgan c'est
vas-y j'ai perdu je continue je continue
ma quête je lâche pas tant que je suis
pas arrivé
sur les réseaux etc il y a plus en plus
de gens
qui me critiquent qui aiment pas ce que
je fais qui me le font savoir
on voit des DM commente mes postes un
ami il y a beaucoup plus de négativité
autour de moi
j'ai l'impression que il y a une grande
partie de gens qui attendent ma chute
j'ai du mal à le
[Musique]
l'encaisser à l'enregistrer
je sens cette pression de
on sait pas vraiment si ouais il a eu de
la chance pour la ceinture etc je
ressens beaucoup ça et ça a beaucoup
joué sur mon état mental
à la mort je mérite pas tu vois il dit
je mérite pas genre je suis là juste
parce que j'ai des followers
je suis parti en Ukraine j'ai fait des
pesées gros ils ont sorti déguns et tous
les gens ils voulaient se tirer dessus
j'ai combattu dans les endroits bizarres
tu vois j'aurais pu mourir tu vois
les gens ils sont là ils disent ah il
mérite pas un analyse ça va pas comment
c'était dur vous arrivez juste là c'est
bon et j'aurais proposé de venir à
l'entraînement il y en a jamais aucun
qui est venu
pour voir pour voir si je suis vraiment
plaqué parce que mec si c'est ça ça veut
dire il a une expertise
un niveau connais c'est un expert
exactement
[Musique]
bon du coup le combat est annoncé donc
le premier octobre je combat à Londres
vous pouvez prendre vos places
d'ailleurs le combat c'est le premier
octobre
n'hésitez pas à venir vous pouvez
prendre vos places c'est à Londres le
public il est autorisé ceux qui veulent
venir vous pouvez venir venez même il
faut une équipe de malade la salle elle
va pas être grande ça veut dire si on
peut avoir toutes les places ça peut
être incroyable
comme on peut voir c'est bien rangé
voilà une vraie chambre de Fighters
parce que c'est la seule chose que je
fais je mange là ça va tu t'es bien
reposé là ouais ça va aussi partir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une quinzaine de personnes il faut que
j'optimise le temps pour que quand moi
je fais rien il fasse des trucs tu vois
bien sec
[Applaudissements]
on fait comment on met de l'intensité on
met pas d'intensité tu veux comment ce
matin au fur et à mesure
là ça a tout changé la ceinture je suis
vraiment énervé
je me lève le matin je suis énervé je me
couche le soir je pense à ça tu vois ça
ça m'a fait des insomnies
les premières semaines quand j'ai repris
l'entraînement je veux parler plus à
personne je suis un peu plus égoïste
maintenant je pense beaucoup plus à moi
je suis plus méchant aussi pendant les
entraînements je voulais pas trop faire
mal à mes partenaires ou quoi maintenant
je m'en fiche toi si je mets KO le mec
tu vois tant pis
parce que le jour du combat faut que je
sois capable de le faire de mettre dans
dans le mindset d'être méchant de
chercher à faire mal je suis beaucoup
plus méchant à l'entraînement
encore encore encore encore
[Musique]
je le sais il le sait tu le sais c'est
toi c'est toi c'est toi et je vais te le
répéter toute la soirée et je veux que
toi tu te dise non ta [__] de tête mon
gars tu dis c'est mignon
cage que toi il mérite pas
c'est parfait
je suis vraiment dans un état d'esprit
où je retrouve comment je j'ai été au
début quand j'ai commencé en pro et il y
avait pas de gestion d'énergie sur 5 ans
ou quoi moi le combat il commençait le
mec je suis rentré dans direct
je suis en train de revenir à ce Morgan
là mais avec le capacités que j'ai
maintenant
et je pense que ça va faire un sacré
mélange toi je veux que sur ce combat là
que les mecs qui disent [__] nous a
jamais sorti ça tu me l'endors tu le
termines tu le finis je vais au
cinquième round je vais pas à la
décision j'en veux pas j'en veux pas une
fois on s'est fait avoir pas de
dans ta vie quand tu fais une erreur tu
la fais pas deux fois tu me l'as montré
tu nous le montre tous les jours rentre
à toi dans la tête je veux pas
ok tout le monde bon tu es encore un peu
le visage fatigué mais comparaisse
maintenant ça n'a rien à voir donc là je
suis en train de manger du saumon et du
riz
donc on reprend des forces pour demain
là je regarde le film de Mohamed Ali
petit poisson voilà tu connais là on
sait c'est l'heure de Larry Jenna je
mange Goku
ensuite bah je vais dormir repos et
demain les frères et les sœurs
c'est parti on va ramener ce qui me
revient de droit on a trop travaillé
vous avez vu de toute façon pas de
triche pas de voilà on se trouve des
excuses ma charbonnier pendant c'est le
moment de prendre du plaisir il faut que
ça paye faut qu'on fasse la masterclass
et qu'on rentre avec cette ceinture et
qu'on passe à la suite
à demain
surprises
avec du sang sur moi
à la maison frérot on a la baraque ici
et lui il va se prendre son cas où ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
laisse-le faire le coq
j'ai pas le droit à l'erreur tu vois si
je rate le coche là je pense que l'UFC
je peux faire une croix dessus
j'ai pas le droit de perdre j'ai plus le
droit de perdre c'est comme si on dit
est à ta famille qui est enfermé qui
part faut que tu Bates telle personne
pour là il y a les sauver tu vois moi
c'est la même chose tu vois alors si je
veux que mon père il arrête de
travailler et tout je dois le battre lui
c'est obligé
j'ai beaucoup de pression sur les
épaules
j'ai du mal à mettre dedans à être hyper
focus genre lâchant vraiment la pression
que moi je me mets tout seul la pression
des réseaux la pression de l'attente du
résultat de tous ces gens qui attendent
derrière tu vois c'était énorme pour moi
et
je faisais vraiment pas je me loupe faut
pas je me loupe
j'ai des voix dans ma tête j'ai des voix
dans ma tête
tu es pas si fort que ça peut-être de la
chance tout ce que j'ai lu en fait et
c'est là que ça ressort à ce moment là
[Musique]
je pense que Morgan pour lui c'est la
descente aux enfers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a les fins de Français qui sont là
enfin franchement tout était là pour que
ce soit un grand moment
et tout il m'a régalé
on avait un petit peu en travers
la défaite pour nous qui est pas une
défaite contre vulcanique donc on a dit
là on va tout brûler on va mettre une
ambiance de dingue
c'était impossible il y avait trop de il
y avait le feu sacré en nous c'était
c'était impossible
elle est extraordinaire l'image de
Morgan couve les bras je sais pas si tu
le vois ces images donc je parle dans la
cage il ouvre les bras tu vois la no
morevery derrière avec la grande bâche
the French party Nova
attends
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est en termes de MMA pure
c'est un des plus beaux combats que j'ai
vu moi
mon adversaire
franchement je
je veux pas passer pour un présomptueux
tu vois ou quoi mais je vais le tuer
je vais lui faire mal tu vois là là on
plante
je peux pas dire ce que je pense on va
dire que je suis un je suis un détraqué
mais non j'y vais dans un état d'esprit
ouais c'est vraiment ouais c'est la
guerre dans ma tête
c'est ma vie tu vois qu'un jeu je peux
mourir dans la cage là il y a pas de
souci
il y a dès le premier round on a senti
que c'était un combat qui allait être
super engagé
[Applaudissements]
il est extraordinaire
que tout passe bon
il est au-dessus partout il fait ce
qu'on lui demande il va chercher sa
ceinture et là tu vois que il y a de
l'agressivité
[Applaudissements]
les deux premiers rangs tout se passe
super bien je me dis ah ouais c'est bon
la poche mais je me dis ah ça paye je
suis vraiment fort tu vois
[Applaudissements]
franchement ce que tu fais c'est super
je tourne la tête et voyous et aussi il
est pas bien elle est pas bien
physiquement il est pas bien mentalement
ça se voit et je lui dis je lui dis
Morgan accélère s'il te plaît
[Musique]
mon dernier le feu vert j'y vais à fond
le combat repart boum boum boum ça
touche j'y vais à fond et je sens que je
lui marche dessus et qui n'a pas la
solution
[Musique]
on a pris trop de confiance
et prend le crochet bras arrière qu'on a
travaillé à l'entraînement qu'on se dit
on le sent pas celui-là il le prend il
touche
et je joue à double
et je me dis
qu'est-ce qui se passe wow je vais pas
me prendre un KO quand même là
je regarde je vois deux pollueuses
comment je vais faire là
instantanément sur le moment moi je vois
que son œil il a sauté
la pression dans le public autour de moi
on a tous le cœur serré on est pas bien
on se dit pas finir comme ça impossible
très difficile quand hugs le tient en
étranglement
pour moi c'était c'était horrible
j'avais le j'avais plus respirer
clairement
[Musique]
attention
si vraiment ça tape trop je vais être
obligé d'arrêter arriver à un moment
et je suis inquiet vraiment c'est la
famille c'est plus que c'est le notre
petit mais je peux pas lui dire
d'arrêter je peux pas lui dire il est
dans son combat il y a rien qui est
perdu
ça veut dire qu'il a fait deux derniers
rangs les deux les plus difficiles
souvent parce que c'est là où on est
fatigué on a pris des coups on a donné
hein
j'efface cette douleur enfin j'ai mis
prête pas attention comme si tu vois ici
j'avais mis un masque et ça existe pas
et j'y vais à fond et lui aussi mais ça
cogne
il s'est rappelé je pense depuis chez
Nick et s'est dit je vais pas vu la même
chose même s'il manque un œil même si je
suis fatigué même si j'ai mal je vais
pas vivre la même chose je veux leur
montrer que que je vais gagner ce combat
c'est une blessure franchement c'est dur
de combattre avec ça très très dur et ça
peut avoir des conséquences très graves
[Applaudissements]
à moins il a fait pour finir ses combats
avec un ayant moins je sais pas qui
d'autre aurait pu faire ça
père
non après on a un petit peu dans le
public on se dit ouais c'est la décision
qu'est-ce que ça va être environ
15 jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur cette chaîne je suis seul face à
moi-même face à mes pensées et puis
après c'est là que je me rends compte tu
vois du combat que j'ai fait et tout on
me dit que c'est un combat incroyable
mais quand tu perds le combat et la
boîte incroyable c'est pas toi qui l'a
gagné donc
je préfère toujours être le vainqueur
donc c'est des sentiments durs à
accepter sur la chaise en fait tu es un
peu en bataille contre toi-même entre
est-ce que je t'ai mis tout et je remets
la faute sur quelqu'un d'autre du style
en allant c'est parce que je sais pas
moi j'ai pas bu assez d'eau tu vois
l'interroom ou c'est de la faute de mon
coach c'est de la faute de je sais pas
qui franchement
comme une merde je pense que je me
sentais comme une merde à ce moment là
c'est à dire que
le combat c'est juste le l'aboutissement
de toute une préparation de plusieurs
mois
je me suis entraîné comme un ouf
j'ai perdu 6 mois de ma vie pour ce
combat et en plus j'ai une fracture
j'en ai comme as j'ai mal j'ai le nez
cassé j'avais mal ailleurs forcément vu
que c'est un combat et tu as pas gagné
parce que encore quand tu es comme ça et
que tu as gagné c'est tu vois ça passe
oublié et là quand tu perds tu vois j'ai
fait un kitting j'ai fait un régime j'ai
raté l'anniversaire de telle personne
telle personne telle toi c'est ça tout
ça que tu penses quand tu es sur ta
chaîne
[Musique]
j'ai de la chance c'était pas à côté de
la cage donc ils ont pas vu mon œil et
après moi je leur ai pas envoyé de
photos je les ai pas vu pendant une
semaine pour pour pas qu'il voit ça tu
vois parce que ma mère elle va pas
[__] si on voit ça
ça va
moi ça va quoi
[Musique]
c'est un bon combat quand même
si forcément
on est là on peut le soutenir mais on
peut rien faire je sais pas s'il était
en souffrance je pense après mais nous
moi j'avais très mal je me disais
tiens là mon petit garçon lui fait mal
ils sont armée elle était là on a mis on
a mis le feu aventure
ok moi je vais aller les voir
bisous
[Musique]
mes parents
mon père il peut plus regarder des
combats c'est dur pour ma famille c'est
dur pour tout le monde pour tous les
gens autour de moi c'est et c'est encore
plus dur pour moi parce que je vois que
c'est dur pour eux
[Musique]
en plus d'avoir l'impression de décevoir
ma famille toi tu es un peu l'impression
que tu as des suit tout le monde tu vois
et tous ces gens qui me suivent qui me
soutiennent qui me donnent beaucoup de
force tu vois j'ai peur que les décevoir
je le fais autant pour eux pour moi
après c'est genre tu vois j'ai envie
qu'ils kiffe qui qui est trop bien
dessus ça carrière la langue tu m'en
parles les émotions qui montent parce
que je me rappelle on est sorti mais
tous nos lunettes noires on était en
train de pleurer comme des comme des
gosses et quand on est tous sorti on a
dit avec a dit on a dit à tout le monde
les gars attendez
imaginez regardez imaginez comment c'est
dur pour nous imaginez que lui dans quel
état il est les gars
regardez comment il nous a fait vibrer
là pendant 25 minutes l'entrée le machin
le bidule mais non on peut pas le
laisser partir comme ça
ouais les Français sont jamais vu ça
l'équipage il était là
merci d'être venu et merci à toi
merci et pour Morgo
[Applaudissements]
donne-moi
bravo Morgan
[Applaudissements]
ce qui a été décevant je pense pour
Morgan c'est que les gens ils lui ont
craché dessus
[Musique]
tous les gens qui l'ont dit c'est un
corail du jour le roi est devenu un
mendiant et c'est ça je pense pour lui
aussi ça a été ça a dû être
et là il a vu la face cachée en fait la
façon des réseaux sociaux et ça a été
c'est comme si en fait c'était eux qui
lui avaient cassé le planche orbital il
était super atteint par les commentaires
de tout le monde sur les vidéos YouTube
sur Twitter c'est quelque chose qui l'a
énormément touché même moi à en côtoyant
Morgan j'ai reçu des messages de mecs
dans des DM je dis ouais les gars vous
vous rendez compte de ce que vous dites
c'est chaud quand même ça a été
extrêmement difficile pour lui et
ils n'en parlait pas c'est à dire que je
l'ai découvert en fouillant sur les
réseaux sociaux quand je voyais qu'il
était sur son téléphone et que je le
voyais triste là je disais les
commentaires et je me disais mais en
fait il faut qu'il arrête à lire d'aller
lire ça faut qu'il arrête
[Musique]
tout le monde était de me mordant tout
le monde disait que non concrètement
qu'il était pas fait pour ça que c'était
pas un bon combattant qu'il a perdu qui
avait pas de doute dessus c'est lui qui
perd c'est sûr et certain on lui disait
aussi que le FC c'est fini il aura
jamais niveau pour y aller
que c'est un combattant un peu des
réseaux sociaux en fait un combattant
d'Instagram parce qu'il a beaucoup
d'abonnés sur Instagram
en fait tous pris de son travail depuis
des années a été réduit à un combat et à
une défaite
ça a été une période archi archi archi
dur
elles ont eu le dos des gens avec qui je
parlais et tout plus de messages plus de
nouvelles
[Applaudissements]
personne me demande si ça va tu vois
peut-être je fais plus jamais pouvoir
combattre tu vois on sait pas
pas de message de Jean-Pierre proches je
veux dire ah ouais en fait c'est vrai le
truc de tout le monde est là quand il y
a la lumière et grâce à redescend il y a
plus personne
et à côté on me critique et on allume de
tous les côtés [__] mais je comprends
pas tu vois qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour
mériter ça tu vois
[Musique]
et je me disais ce que tu veux vraiment
est-ce que ce que le sport ça te manque
parce que le MMA ça te manque qu'est-ce
que je veux faire de ma vie à ce moment
là genre je me suis dit est-ce que
est-ce que j'ai vraiment envie
de lui assez
franchement si le fond du trou c'était
une image c'est l'image du fond du trou
et au fond et tu regardes la lumière
là-haut et je peux pas aller plus bas
que ça
[Musique]
on a comme info
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu moi je vous donne rendez-vous demain
à 18h sur la chaîne Youtube de brut pour
visionner l'épisode final de cette série
et n'oubliez pas non plus que l'UFC
Paris du 2 septembre sera retransmis
samedi soir en direct sur RMC Sport
merci encore pour votre soutien à très
vite